Nobody is really quite sure how the tradition
of waking up NASA astronauts with pieces of
music got started; NASA itself only notes
that “Wake-up calls are a long-standing
NASA tradition.”
However, archivist and historian Colin Fries,
who has painstakingly tracked down every example
of a song or clip played by NASA in such a
scenario going all the way back to 1965, is
fairly confident that the earliest example
of such a wake-up call occurred during the
1965 Gemini 6 mission on December 16th, likely
as a joke.
During this mission, astronauts Walter Schirra
and Tom Stafford were woken up by a recording
of singer Jack Jones and Hello Dolly.
According to Fries, earlier missions in the
Gemini program and the manned missions of
the earlier still Mercury program were too
short to require the need for wake-up calls.
This musical wake-up call quickly became a
regular occurrence intended as a way of bolstering
morale while allowing astronauts a few minutes
to wake up slowly before having to respond
to ground control.
Over the years, wake-up calls became one of
NASA’s most beloved traditions, with the
role of picking the songs given to the mission’s
Capsule Commander (CAPCOM)…
Yes, just to be clear, not only do these people
get to put CAPCOM for NASA on their resume,
but they can also add in “Space DJ”.
The songs chosen over the years have been
wildly eclectic, ranging from classical music
by composers like Bach and Beethoven to the
latest hits of Metallica and the Beastie Boys.
These songs are largely chosen in accordance
with the tastes of the astronauts aboard whatever
craft.
Towards this end, before a mission, the individual
tasked with handling communication with those
in orbit (the aforementioned CAPCOM) will
often ask family and loved ones of the astronauts
if there’s a particular piece of music said
individual might like to hear while in space.
Thanks to the extensive records NASA keeps,
we not only know every song played for astronauts
in orbit since 1965, we also have the astronaut’s
responses to some of the more unusual choices
played.
For example, for a 2008 mission aboard the
Space Shuttle Atlantis, officially designated
as STS-123, CAPCOM played a brief snippet
of the theme song from the presumably epic
film Godzilla VS Space Godzilla as well as
part of the Blue Oyster Cult song, Godzilla,
for Japanese astronaut Takao Doi, signing
off by saying:
Good morning Endeavour.
Doi san, ohayo gozaimasu, from mission control
here in Houston, take on today like a monster.
An amused Doi responded that he was “happy
to hear Godzilla,” before himself signing
off to get to work.
According to Fries’ extensive archives,
Godzilla’s iconic theme song is apparently
a popular choice for Japanese astronauts,
as are the themes from other well-known films
like Star Wars, Star Trek and Rocky.
Predictably, songs with a space theme are
also popular choices, with David Bowie’s
Space Oddity and Elton John’s Rocket Man
being noted as some of the most commonly played.
Given the inevitably varied tastes of astronauts
taking part in missions, the choice of songs
has caused some good-natured friction between
them.
A notable example is the song Wild Blue Yonder–
better known simply as The Air Force Song,
chosen as many astronauts come from the Air
Force.
This has led to complaints from members of
the Navy taking part in missions when it’s
played multiple times.
On another occasion, the aforementioned Steve
Robinson found himself with something of a
dilemma on his hands when a superior insisted
he play Wild Blue Yonder, while the wife of
one of the astronauts asked him to play a
Barry Manilow’s, A Little Traveling Music,
Please; stuck between a rock and a hard place,
Robinson’s solution?
I played ’em back to back.
I thought they would cancel each other out…
The only complaints were from the navy guys
on the crew.
But I’m not sure if they were complaining
about the Air Force Song or Barry Manilow…
In addition to songs, NASA has, at various
points, played private messages recorded by
the astronauts’ loved ones (including the
occasional singing of “Happy Birthday”
where applicable) and even occasional messages
from celebrities.
Notable examples of the latter include personalised
greetings from William Shatner, Paul McCartney
and Elton John, a skit performed by Jim Henson
involving Miss Piggy, and even a song sung
by Darth Vader set to backing music from The
Beatles.
Perhaps best of all was the crew of Atlantis
on November 25, 1991 being woken to none other
than Patrick Stewart stating (with Star Trek:
The Next Generation theme music playing in
the background),
Space: the final frontier.
This is the voyage of the Space Shuttle Atlantis.
Its ten-day mission: To explore new methods
of remote sensing and observation of the planet
Earth…
To seek out new data on radiation in space,
and a new understanding of the effects of
microgravity on the human body…
To boldly go where two hundred and fifty-five
men and women have gone before!
Hello Fred, Tom, Story, Jim, Tom, and especially
Mario — this is Patrick Stewart, choosing
not to outrank you as Captain Jean-Luc Picard,
saying that we are confident of a productive
and successful mission.
Make it so.
Finally, while it’s noted that ultimate
control over the playlist in space is down
to the discretion of CAPCOM alone, it’s
generally agreed not to wake up astronauts
with too startling of music.
This said, some CAPCOMs have chosen to ignore
this for their own amusement, such as Commander
Chris Hadfield once waking up the crew with
an extra loud U2 rendition of the Mission:
Impossible theme song.
In another somewhat jarring instance, in 2001
the crew of mission STS-98 was woken to perhaps
the most annoying song in the history of music-
Who Let the Dogs Out.
(And, in fact, Rolling Stone named it the
third most annoying song in history behind
My Humps, by Black Eyed Peas, and- mother
of god- Macarena, by Los Del Rio. *shudders*)
Why was Who Let the Dogs Out chosen for the
crew of STS-98?
Kenneth Cockrell, the pilot for the mission,
was previously a member of mission STS-69
in 1995, with the crew of that mission nicknamed
the Dog Crew II.
As for today, with the retirement of the Space
Shuttle program, this wake-up call tradition
has partially been left in the dustbin of
history, though occasionally is still observed
on the International Space Station, and presumably
will be reinstituted as a regular activity
once NASA begins sending people to space themselves
again.